well good afternoon everyone
thank you for coming today to today's
first print principles on first Friday's
lecture an ongoing program sponsored by
the Hillsdale College Allen P Kirby jr.
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship it's my pleasure to welcome
you today my name is David Bob I service
director of the center today we have a
most important topic and I'm pleased to
welcome a good friend and colleague John
48 I would encourage you to if you're
interested in pursuing the themes that
he's going to be discussing today the
electoral college the national popular
vote all of the attendant controversy
surrounding that a very fair overview of
this whole debate was put together by
John a few years ago for the American
Enterprise Institute it's called after
the people vote a guide to the electoral
college and it lays out in very succinct
fashion the arguments for and against
NPV and for and against the electoral
college it's a great debate and pleas
that that John is able to join us today
we're going to continue the conversation
for those of you who are with us in
person after our formal presentation
this morning so we'll change this room
and have an opportunity then to continue
the conversation over lunch for those of
you can stay so we'd encourage you to to
do that the Hillsdale College lecture
series on first principles focuses as
many of you know on topics of timely
import and today today's topic is
particularly timely we're now only one
year out seems like a long time but the
election cycle such as it is this these
months are going to go by very quickly
and indeed more than half of the states
necessary to put the national popular
vote plan into
have already taken action so it's a it's
a good debate and we're looking forward
to this conversation to introduce our
speaker formally it's Hillsdale College
jr. John Brooks who this semester is
interning at the Heritage Foundation
Center for principals and politics john
john Fortier is director of the
democracy project at the bipartisan
policy center
previously he was a research fellow at
the American Enterprise Institute where
he also served as the principal
contributor to the AEI election reform
project and the executive director of
the continuity of government Commission
his books include after the people vote
a guide to the electoral college and he
has been a regular columnist for the
hill and Politico he received his BA
from Georgetown University his PhD in
political science from Boston College
and has taught at Harvard University the
University of Pennsylvania and the
University of Delaware today he will be
speaking on the topic of is the
Electoral College outdated please join
me in welcoming dr. John 48
thank you John thank you David
and thank you to Hillsdale and the Kirby
Center I have had the opportunity in
Washington before through David who
we've known since know each other since
graduate school to speak to Hillsdale
students in this program but the last
time I spoke to them it was a wonderful
conversation great students but in in
more modest surroundings and David at
that time took me across the street here
and showed me some some townhouses
beautiful great location beautiful
facades of the townhouse but when you
open the door the the wear-and-tear
showed it was what you'd expect in a I
don't know how old 100 year old or so
town house well I I came back a few
weeks ago and it was as if we opened the
Wardrobe door and there was the world of
gnarnia before us or some remarkable
place inside the door that that I had I
knew would be impressive but what you
have here and what you've built both as
a program but also a physical product is
really quite impressive so I'm very
pleased to be here with you here and for
those of you watching watching from afar
David asked me to address a topic and I
certainly want to leave some time for
questions so I don't take all the time
but the topic is is the Electoral
College outdated so I'm tempted just say
no and just wander over here and we'll
have lunch and so you know my cards are
on the table but I guess I I'm gonna
take a little more time to to lay out
the case first to really think about
what is the Electoral College people I
think know mostly what that means but of
course that term is not in the
Constitution itself and I think all of
what we mean by the Electoral College is
not in the Constitution itself some of
it is some of it is in the Constitution
some of which we've changed a bit some
of it is in laws federal laws the
election day when it said the dates then
the electors meet some procedures that
that deal with how those those
electrodes are counted electoral votes
congressional rules also affect that if
if it comes to some disputed election
there are certainly things in just
Congress's rules not in law that that
affect the electoral college it's also
the case that we have States and I think
states are something that we're going to
talk a fair amount about today states
have a role in the electoral college but
they've also made some decisions and
individual decisions which shape the way
we think about the electoral college the
most important one being that most
states forty-eight of the states today
allah-allah
all of the electors in their states to
the winner of that state that has not
always been the case does not have to be
the case a couple states do it another
way and as David mentioned there is
there is an effort which essentially is
looking to move towards a national
popular vote but is taking advantage of
them I don't necessarily think unfair
advantage but taking advantage of this
idea that the states themselves have
some say as to how those electors are
allocated so the Electoral College is
not just a a one thing it's not just in
the Constitution it's a whole set of
things that we we put together and has
evolved into parts of it have evolved to
where we are today
the the constitutional partly I mean why
don't we talk about that first the
constitutional part I would say the
essence of the constitutional part is
that the the votes for president do not
come all from from one place but come
from 51 places with the District of
Columbia now participating the electoral
college the the votes in those
jurisdictions matter for president and
the electors themselves those who are
coming out of the elections that we have
in November those electors who finally
like the president don't come together
in one place it's a misnomer to call it
the Electoral College as if we thought
everyone would show up in one room and
have a vote and decide who is president
there are 51 different meeting places
for electors and again you know that
shows some place of the states and those
those elections have we that they're
also some backup procedures and I I
guess I don't want to talk too much
about them I certainly people who
criticize that for college criticize
this this portion of it they say well
what if there is no majority in the
electoral college the presidency is
thrown into the House of Representatives
with a strange sort of way of voting
vice presidency is thrown into the
Senate that doesn't happen very often so
I'm not that I don't want to talk about
that but certainly it's not the major
feature of the electoral college I don't
think it's the major reason that the
people oppose it but but there are some
constitutional provisions that say what
happens if the electoral college is not
a successful in getting majority and
again on the Constitution we've we've
made some changes the biggest one being
that 12th amendment in 1800 or after the
1800 election the Aaron Burr and
Jefferson election and I've been
impressed by the network of people at
Hillsdale College who know about my talk
in advance and have actually sent me
manuscripts I've acquired some very
interesting pieces on the electoral
college just in the last week or so the
one of which was making the case for the
original electoral college why why not
go back to that that set of laws and and
essentially arguing that the the current
arrangement is too much connected to
political parties I think there's
there's some truth to that I don't
advocate that but I think there's some
truth to the fact that the original
electoral college was a little different
and didn't imagine that there would be
two political parties so you know we've
changed the Constitution in a in a
reasonably significant way in the 12th
amendment but we've also made some other
smaller changes the 20th amendment which
allows which changes the dates of when
the presidency comes in when Congress
starts thereby changing maybe what
happens who counts the votes the old
Congress the new Congress the
possibility of thinking about what would
happen to President if the presidential
candidate the winning candidate died in
the period between the election and the
January 20th an oration today giving
Congress the power to think about that
by law so there are a number of things
the Constitution that have changed a bit
over time
what about federal law what what kinds
of things in federal law affect our
electoral college a 1 1 I don't think
that people think very much about is we
have a single election day I think many
people think well of course
have a single Election Day hoods the
it's the first Tuesday after the first
Monday in November every every four
years for president but it didn't have
to be that way
in fact early on just like in our
primary system today states would have
their elections or selecting their
electors in different way at different
times it was a rolling set of election
so you know one thing federal law says
and has said since about the 1840s they
say we're gonna have one Election Day
and in November and that's that's sort
of part of our electoral college
landscape the dates when the electors
meet we know that they meet in the
States and in state capitals but when
they meet just set by federal law when
the Congress counts the electoral votes
laws of a presidential succession I
mentioned that if a presidential
candidate or vice presidential candidate
dies and then in the interim there are
some laws that would help us figure out
who might step in or who might be
president on January 20th or if somehow
the election was not resolved at all if
we just had no resolution the election
may be maybe there's a law that there is
a law that would tell us what would
happen so there are all sorts of things
in federal law I mentioned congressional
procedure there are rules some of which
they've been shrining law about how to
count electors what if they're disputed
so there's there's some some parts of
that that are just in Congress's rules
and in the States I guess I hear I want
to spend a little more time and think
about the tremendous variation that's
allowed for States I told you that that
more or less since the early part of the
19th century early to mid 1820s 1830s
states have tended to allot all of their
electors and a winner-take-all system if
you win Massachusetts by one vote you
get all the electors it's not split
proportionally it's not done by district
it's almost always done that way they're
a couple of couple of states through
exceptions Maine and Nebraska but it
wasn't the case early early on and here
you have a set of systems that states
had which are very foreign to us I'm
some of them district systems some of
them the legislature directly picking
the the electors South Carolina actually
was
that continued to do that all the way to
the Civil War it was the last holdout
and state or two when they were coming
into the Union that tried it that way
for one time the systems where part of
Maryland had two or three electors and
the other parts were split one two and
three there are all sorts of systems
that that you could imagine to a lot the
electors and the court has more or less
said this is this is okay states have a
great amount of power as to how they
allow their electors practically
speaking almost all the states are
winner-take-all
but in the background there is this idea
that states have the ability to to
decide how to tie to us so how do I sign
electors and so to skip a little bit
ahead and preview what what might come
up in the talk later if you if you're
interested change the electoral college
you might not have to change the
Constitution right there might be things
you can change in federal law there
might be things you could change in
state law and especially in these areas
how you would think about how you assign
the electors Maine and Nebraska again
have a district system they already do
it you may have seen in the newspapers
Pennsylvania has been considering moving
towards a district system but in a
larger sense this national popular vote
initiative is thinking about the states
in that same way that states might have
another way of assigning their electors
not based on who wins their state but
maybe based on the national popular vote
and that I will get to but that's it
comes out of this idea that states have
a lot to say about the electoral college
and how electors are assigned there are
sometimes I'll get to some reasons why
I'm in favor the electoral college but
there are some who make a strong
Federalist case for the electoral
college that it is in some ways a real
institution that defends state's
interests tonight I don't go quite that
far
I certainly do think that there's a
state component and a state component
that matters but for the most part
because states don't pick a electors
directly it's not really a state
government component it isn't something
that says state government has these
rights and the Electoral College by the
way we elect the president
really protecting those it tends to be
the people in the states the the
majorities of people through the country
most most of our electoral college and
way you think or the way we elect our
president is really essentially a
national vote most of the state's votes
in the electoral college
come from the population of the state
but there's a small component to elect
or slike two senators from each state
that comes from the fact that each state
is the state and that means that the the
people in each state have some say the
majority of a state not the government
of a state but the majority of people in
any election have some say about what a
president or who should be president I
think that's important in a number of
ways not to defend really the
prerogatives of state government as much
as to say we are in many ways a federal
union a national country we have a
national electorate but we also do have
majorities that rise up to throw out
state governors or legislatures or
change policy at States and these are
real components of our national policy
but that policymakers at the federal
level should think about at least what
the state majorities are and so I think
there's some some value in that there's
also some value I think in a minor point
of federalism but but one you can
imagine the alternative not being so
good is that there's no one single place
in Washington that runs elections we
think of elections even though we as
Electoral College we think of national
elections but there's no there's the
Federal Election Commission is the
election assistance Commission you can
find these places in Washington and they
have some say about certain laws but as
for who runs elections it's all done at
the state level certainly sometimes at
the local level with state supervision
but the but the primary jurisdiction is
there at the state and one thing that
means is that there's no one place in
Washington that is running an election
and if you want to make that less
abstract and really put it down to
concrete things if a president is
running for reelection want to pick on
this president President Obama's running
free election or President Bush is
running for reelection in 2004
and the federal government is in charge
of running the national election one one
single election there certainly would be
some doubts right people would say is
that president is that government being
fair are they tilting the scales in one
direction one advantage of our system
that it comes out of 51 different places
is it's a whole bunch of different
places all controlled by different
parties and some based on last election
or some based on election a couple years
ago or it's a it's a patchwork but it is
also some ways not concentrated in one
place and again just to you know
reiterate this point the there's no
place that we have a national electorate
the House of Representatives is an
institution based on population
it is meant by the founders to be
broadly representative of the United
States not the states but there are no
districts in the House of
Representatives they go across state
lines there are small inequalities
between a district in Montana that will
be because it only gets one seats larger
than a district in California not the
biggest inequalities but again states
like states lines in terms of election
state control of how elections are run
it's something that pervades all of our
federal institutions so in a way the
Electoral College is not unlike that
what are the arguments against the
Electoral College I'm sure you've heard
them but first I think we should admit
that the Electoral College is not a
particularly popular institution there
are numerous polls they've begun
you haven't changed significantly in the
last 20 30 years you typically have 60
65 percent against the electoral college
they would rather have some sort of
national popular vote now I can make
some arguments against that that it's
not necessarily a burning issue for
people that in the 2000 election for
example I think we rightly focused on
issues of how we administer our
elections voting machines and
registration and all of the things that
we weren't really paying them a lot of
attention to we didn't really focus as
much on the question of well that Al
Gore get more popular votes than George
Bush even though some who were against
the Electoral College wished we would so
maybe there's not a burning desire to do
but I I have no doubt that you know the
average view of the American people is
it's not that they think we should have
the electoral college would be simpler
to have a simple national popular vote
and I know some certainly plenty on the
other side of the argument who say no
state does this right you don't go into
a state to elect your governor with this
complicated system where part of the
state has an elector and it's indirect
that it's you know that it's something
that's natural to us that we have a
executive office for the whole country
maybe we should have a popular vote so
don't think you can make the argument
that there's popular support for it or
that at least that there's not you know
majority support for it it's certainly
against the first argument is that it's
unequal that somehow the Electoral
College is a problem because not
everybody's vote counts the same and
that's there's some truth to that as we
know the Electoral College gives each
state two electors for being a state and
then one or more electors based on its
state population so you can have a
minimum of three the smallest state
Wyoming has has three electors
California it's gonna have fifty five
electors with and if you do though if
you do the math you do the ratio you
find out that the smaller state a person
in a smaller state has somewhat more of
a of a say and I think this in certain
circumstances would be a problem but I
don't think it's a problem today and the
reason I say this is there are some
smaller inequalities but certainly
compared to the Senate Senate is
extremely unequal that the two senators
come from the state of Wyoming to state
senators come from the state of
California the difference in population
is you know forty to fifty times and you
know there's a significant difference
here in the very smallest states there's
there's a little bit more of an
advantage for it for each person but
it's not a large advantage and I mean
just just looking is it an unfair system
I think one question to ask is if this
system were always making Democrats or
Republicans on the short end of the
stick of inequality it would have a hard
time surviving I think it'd be hard if
they were
permanent interest which felt like the
Electoral College was always stacked
against them and you can look to see
that that least is not the case today in
the smallest states because really the
the greatest distortion is in the states
with just one representative or two
representatives after that it's a
relatively equal number of votes per
person and those small states if you
look at the seven states plus the
District of Columbia who have three
electoral votes I think you could say
five of them are Republican North Dakota
South Dakota Montana Wyoming Alaska big
election maybe one of those could go the
other way but be pretty pretty solidly
Republican in an average election and
then Vermont the District of Columbia
Delaware on their Democratic side five
to three slight advantage maybe for
Republicans but not so not so far off
what about two electors what about
states with two electors you have Idaho
which is very Republican you have Rhode
Island Maine and Hawaii which are very
democratic and and then you have New
Hampshire which is which is a swing
state so no it's it's not so different
that the states are smaller states are
not concentrated in just Republican
hands or just in democratic hands and
there there are sometimes people who
make arguments about you know which side
is benefited or not it I think it's
probably true that Republicans have a
slight slight advantage by having some
more in the three four or five three
four five representative or five six
seven
representative category electoral
category but those differences are quite
small so I think it's not an unfair
system in terms of party it's not an
unfair system in terms of region those
states I mentioned they're there all
over the place yeah there are a few more
maybe in New England in the Mountain
West but they're they're certainly
scattered across the country and you
know the argument that it's that is a
burning problem against us because it's
unequal I think is it's not one that
that is keeping people up at night now
the biggest one perhaps the losing
candidate in the popular vote can win
it's absolutely true happening in 2000
now I have some arguments against this
but I you know I want to make these
again modestly because I think if it
were the case that regularly
one party again was on the wrong side of
this all the time I think there would be
a real reason to say well there's some
other virtues the electoral college but
it really isn't fair it's really the
system this is keeping a major majority
in the country from expressing itself
but it's extremely infrequent it
happened of course in 2000 that hadn't
happened in a hundred plus years before
then it's hard to imagine it happening
other than the vote being this close
certainly you can do the math and try to
find some some outlandish scenario where
there are lots and lots of states
falling on one side by just a few votes
and not on the other side but
realistically it seems like we we need
to have a popular vote that was divided
by less than a percent between the two
candidates it's not absolutely clear
which party would benefit again the 2000
election many people thought that it
would go the other way if it went that
way that Bush might be on the short end
of the stick of the electoral college
might win the popular vote and then
finally if it's that close there is the
argument I think a good one that that
candidates would have run their
elections differently right if George
Bush knew that it was try to win the
popular vote he might have spent more
time in Texas run up the score there may
be not as much in some other places and
when you're talking about election that
is decided by less than half of 1% and
there certainly are some opportunities
for ways in which you could think that
the electoral strategy would have been
different so again it's not a it's not a
bad argument it's one that I think
resonates with a number of people but
it's not one that I think is underlying
some tremendous unfairness between the
parties between regions that is
regularly keeping one party one faction
one part of the country down to the
expense of the other some people say
it's complicated it's certainly I mean
I'll pitch my book in this way my book
is meant not to deal so much with the
normal workings of the electoral college
but although abnormal workings what
happens if there's a tie or candidate
dies or there's a disputed election so
there there are all sorts of later
mechanisms but I do think that people
have the the basic understanding that
their voting their state matters that
they get out to help their candidate win
their state that
that helps their candidate and and they
may not know all the details but it's
not a it's not an overly complicated
system in terms of the some of the
basics to more arguments against it when
I when I don't give much credence to and
the other one I do one is that people
lose their votes people throw away their
votes by showing up Republican in
Massachusetts for example knows that his
vote or her vote is a lost vote for the
for the Republican candidate I'm not
predicting Reagan did win in
Massachusetts but today's climate I
think it would have to be a tsunami of
election for Republicans from
Republicans to even compete in
Massachusetts and so people say well
those people have lost their votes and
similarly Democrats in Idaho and very
Republican places have lost their vote I
have thrown away their vote because of
this electoral college and I guess my my
argument in that is that that's actually
an argument that people use when they
think about the question of whether
people should vote at all leave aside
the electoral college if you know your
candidates gonna lose is your is your
vote a lost vote well in some ways it is
right if if you know that the election
and the polls are all showing your
candidate is down by 10 percent and you
go out and vote anyway your your vote
doesn't contribute at all to that that
particular officeholder when you vote
for senator you don't get 40 percent of
that senators vote because forty percent
of you voted for them and it's it's the
problem of anytime we elect a single
person in office some on the losing side
get zero part of that and there's
there's some argument when when talks
about legislators which have a lot of
people in them that you've some
countries we have proportional
representation where the the losing side
gets a share of the votes but here we
really have a winner-take-all system in
almost every office there's house of
representatives Senate or president so
the idea that that somehow the electoral
college particularly encourages lost
votes I think is not true if we had a
national popular vote system there would
be a way in which we could say the same
thing any time we have an office with
one person there are always people who
are not
get a share of that of the winning
candidate there they're going to be on
the losing side and have essentially
zero even if they get 49% of the vote
the argument I think that that we should
take a little more seriously one of the
weaknesses of the electoral college and
that we might think that there are some
things that we want to change or around
the edges or or with state or federal
law not an advocate constitutional
change in this area is that that we
spend a lot of time in just a few states
that that argument is made and it is
true empirically that if you live in
Ohio or now Virginia where I live which
didn't used to be a swing state you
would see ad after ad you will be sick
of political ads you may already be sick
of political ads but there are states
that really matter I think there's a
handful of states and whether that's 10
or 12 states or you know slightly larger
or slightly smaller number each time
it's certainly not 50 states and the
amount of campaign resources spent in
Alaska and Vermont and very Republican
and very democratic places is a lot
smaller than the amount that they spent
in these swing states and I think
there's both a good side and a bad side
to that but I do have some worries about
that I do think that it would make sense
that we care very much about all the
states that that people in a variety of
places are motivated to participate and
be part of this election that elects the
president and I do think that there are
some some worries about that now there's
some countervailing arguments that I I
accept them but I still think maybe
there's some more we could do in this
area the countervailing arguments are
well sometimes these states change they
change over time some states that are
swing states today might not be in 10
years 12 years some states that were
once are not anymore
there are other parts of the process we
have primaries state like South Carolina
might not be particularly interesting in
the general election I think the
Republicans probably gonna win but it's
interesting the Republican side it would
be interesting and a Democratic primary
to be important then we'd spend some
time there there are places that people
go to raise money right people go to
states to
find supporters and raise money even if
they don't think that state is very
important as a swing state California in
New York get a lot of attention by both
Republicans and Democrats in that sense
and you do have the you do have the case
that the candidates are just generally
or people citizens are generally
motivated to vote we have low turnout by
most standards it's true but there are
lots of people in states who feel it as
a national election who watched the
watch the debates who come out no matter
what if their state is not at play it's
true absolutely that the turnout is
lower in states that are not competitive
that are not swing states but not
dramatically lower so there still is a
core of either civic virtue people want
to vote or that they think it's
important as the national matter to to
express their opinion so I do think
there's some countervailing arguments
but I think it would also be useful to
think about how we spread our our votes
around what did the arguments for the
electoral college I mentioned them
briefly but I guess I make a more modest
version of all of them a kind of
federalism yes but not one that says
this is the institution that protects
state government or state rights as much
as it is that we are a country we have a
some ways we have a national majority
but we also do have these state matiz
state elections that bring in Republican
governors or Democratic governors or
bring in and out change in the
legislature and change in policy states
are unlike congressional districts our
real thing that's right congressional
districts could change here and there
we're changing them now or redistricting
they can look different tomorrow they
have no real permanent status but states
do and so majorities and States
political cultures and states are part
of our majority they're not the whole of
it I don't argue that our national
majority is just an assemblage of all
the states majorities because there is a
sense in which the office is federal as
well as as national but but there
certainly is something there in terms of
wanting to have something about
majorities have presidential candidates
care what matters to people in Ohio or
close places it's also something about
moderating influence again I I have some
some worries that that our candidates do
not spend enough time in a lot of places
only in these these swing states but the
swing states are places that are
competitive or someone in the middle and
if we're worried about our parties being
out here and out here right and left and
not enough thinking about what's in the
middle the focus on swing states is
something of a pullback to the middle
yes some of those states themselves can
be polarized but focusing on them rather
than simply trying to gin up your base
in very fair Republican or very
democratic places it's not a wholly
unhealthy thing so I think there's a
kind of modest federalism argument and a
modest moderating element to the
electoral college there's another
argument which I I do make and I but is
not always accepted is that there is
some support in electoral college for
the two-party system
there's argument about this because
there certainly is political science
theory that says anytime you have two
people running in a winner-take-all
election leave out the electoral college
just to have a national popular vote
you're gonna attend to having two
parties the systems that have many
parties usually split up that vote and
have proportional representation you
don't have to win one office when you
have one office the the center of
gravitation is to have two ideas and
competing for this so it may be that
other systems also help the two-party
system but one way in which our country
being a large 50 state very broad
diverse country is that it's hard to
it's hard to be a national party just
pop up overnight right you have we have
some people Ross Perot who became
national figures did reasonably well
created a party but I don't know if
you've met any of the Reform Party
people in Congress there aren't any all
right the Reform Party has died it's
very hard to put roots in your your
party and so partly because the
electoral college and having to win in
more regions than one you can certainly
have a dominant base in a region but you
can't just be a southern party or just
northeastern party you have to be
successful in a number of places you
have to do reasonably well at state
level you have to have representatives
and the Electoral College I think makes
it just that much you know that the
parties that come out of our system have
to be reasonably broad have some roots
in a bunch of places and it's hard to
recreate so I think it is you know
somewhat supportive of the two-party
system and finally there's there a few
things that I would point to that just
that we resolve things more clearly it's
not that we never have problems 2000 we
had some significant problems but we had
to resolve those problems in Florida and
one of the quickly talked about the
national popular vote but if you imagine
having a closer contested election that
was a nationwide vote and try to think
about the way in which we would try to
resolve ballots close election disputed
things with different state rules the
they left for college in some ways
limits that to a state or maybe a baby a
couple states but doesn't allow this to
be a wholly national recount so the
national popular vote and just quickly I
think it's it is the the most
significant challenge to the electoral
college there been people wanting to get
rid of the electoral college for quite a
while and essentially they felt the only
way they could do it was by amending the
Constitution if you changed it
essentially said we were no longer in
elect electors we're going to have a
national popular vote that that's very
hard hurdle to get past a couple
two-thirds of the House and Senate
three-quarters of the states and no
there are a couple other methods but you
know basically a very significant
supermajority to do it what the what the
advocates of national popular vote have
have I think ingeniously latched on to
is this idea that states have a lot of
leeway states may have a lot of say in
how their electors are assigned and what
they essentially are saying is if a
state wants to up front say whoever
comes into my state I'm not gonna really
base the electors on whether you win in
my state or not I'm gonna give we're
gonna give all the electors for them
let's say the state of California to the
winner of the National popular vote
george john mccain could lose in in
california but win nationally and all of
California's electoral votes would go to
john mccain even though the people of
california had wanted brocco bomb so
it's it's if enough states the idea is
if enough states do this if states that
add up to 270 electoral votes then
essentially will have a natural popular
vote we won't call it that will still
have electors from the electoral college
meeting in december but those electoral
electors will all have been selected by
this method that says states you know
look to the national popular vote select
people who are loyal to that and have
the have those people vote for the
national popular vote winner and my fort
no i'm not for the electoral college i'm
not for the national popular vote in any
way but is it unconstitutional you know
i i don't think so i think courts have
been pretty clear that it is allowed
that states have great leeway in what
they do with these these electors there
are some people who make the case that
states couldn't just delegate their
power to the opinions of other states
I'm not I'm not sure I buy that they are
they are making some sort of decision as
to what to do that state by by the state
legislature passing this law and I think
the courts essentially would back them
up but there's there was some
disagreement about that but I think most
people would think it is constitutional
is it ingenious in some ways it is and
you know would there be problems well
aside from the the arguments for or
against whether you know it's a good
idea or not are there some practical
problems yes one people point to is and
I don't actually think this is very
serious that these states are forming a
kind of compact and they're agreeing
that this doesn't take effect until a
number of states do it they're not going
to California this time even though it
has just passed the law is not going to
give its votes to the Republic and if
the Republican wins it's going to give
it to the winner of the state unless all
these other states agree to do it as
well and and there's some question of
the compacts clause the Constitution
that maybe that should be the talk of
another one a day
lectures here but I think there are many
ways for the states to get around that
that's not the big obstacle what one
issue is well what about practical
problems
what is the national popular vote there
really is no such thing it's a number we
come up with it's a number that we go to
the states and say okay tell us what the
final vote was you kind of add it all up
but there's no one official vote right
there's no place in Washington that
keeps that it's a it's a something we
can all calculate and for the most part
that doesn't matter in an election
that's not that close but in an election
that is close it does matter a lot one
states and we see this approach have
very different ways of administering
elections some vote by mail some have
longer hours some have different rules
about felons voting so all sorts of
things can affect who shows up at the
polls and who doesn't how they count
absentee ballots and so we would have a
national popular vote but we might have
some very different rules in different
places and I think those who are for
this don't appreciate that in a way a
national popular vote means changing a
lot of things changing the the states
would have to have almost a very uniform
system and I think that's very hard to
do it would be very hard to have a
recount I think that's that's a that's a
very obvious point right now states have
laws about recounts but it's only about
their state so if we're very close in
California that California could recount
its ballots between John McCain and
Barack Obama but it couldn't force other
states to have recounts and so you could
have a case where the national popular
vote is very very close but no states
are close or only some states over there
who don't even we're not even believing
this national popular vote are are close
so you could have a number of real
practical problems with with this with
this national popular vote so I guess
I'm gonna end with that the electoral
college I think does deserve a kind of
modest events it seems to work
reasonably well there's some problems
with the alternatives doesn't seem to
bias the case in terms of one party or
the other or one region or the other it
embodies a kind of modest federalism
that is worth defending but it is worth
thinking about our there are there some
other things that might make the system
more palatable
I'm not explicitly in favor of the
system that they have in Maine or
Nebraska which is to have some of the
electors selected by state some of them
by district but it might be worth
considering their their alternatives
that might assign electors more on
proportional basis maybe that would
allow candidates to go to more states to
try to win those states maybe they'd be
interested in going to a broader group
of states so I think there's some small
things that we could think about that
would not essentially change the idea of
the Electoral College being a place that
happens in 51 states where one cares
about state majorities and it has a you
know somewhat indirect way of electing
the president I think that that all
could could be still preserved with some
modest changes but I do think it's you
know it's a very significant threat
right now half as David mentioned half
of the half of the votes are there now
49% of the the number you get need to
get to 270 has been achieved by the
people voting advocating for national
popular vote I believe of course it will
get harder and harder as you get closer
to that not 270 number and I don't think
the traditional thought is that maybe
small states will be for the electoral
college because they have a little more
representation in big states will be
against it I think that's not the
breakdown at all I think if you look at
the states that have that have that have
a decayed advocated for it you have you
know the District of Columbia Hawaii
Illinois Maryland Massachusetts New
Jersey Washington state Vermont in
California all essentially democratic
states and there are some exceptions Tom
Golisano the the billionaire from New
York is on the conservative side of the
aisle is for this but for the most part
it's a more of a left-right thing it's
more of a traditionalist worried about
quality debate rather than it is small
state versus large state so I do think
you will likely see more surely
democratic states pick this up and it
could get quite close so if you're if
you're in a state and you're
in a swing state and that state is
considering this I think that's that's
something to watch for so I'm for the
Electoral College I think there's a
modest defense of it that we should
think about we should be open to some
small changes but we should think about
this larger change that is potentially
affecting it's not for this election
maybe not for 2016 but but is slowly
gaining momentum and may end up through
somewhat of the backdoor changing our
electoral college to a national popular
vote system I think there are
microphones right so I'm gonna and I
just go right here thank you for a very
interesting speech but I wondered if you
could comment on what was the wellspring
that the founding fathers drew from for
the ideas for the electoral college well
it I've been certainly there there is
talk in the Federalist Papers that this
is one of the most unobjectionable
things but I will say it was it was it
was a combination of things that came
together whose decided too late in the
process and it depended upon a whole lot
of other things being decided first so
it certainly had to wait for us to
decide what to do about our Congress our
Congress is a is a is a compromise
between the principle of representation
which is represented in the house more
or less every district is equal every
person is roughly represented the same
way in the House of Representatives and
representation the states which is equal
representation in the Senate and so the
Electoral College has you know something
of a something of a mix of these things
it was also true the original electoral
college was a little different than ours
and so the original electoral college
you had these electors had to vote for
or you could elect essentially two
electors and they they believed you
wouldn't have political parties and so
one of the thoughts was you might just
know somebody from your own state not a
country that that everybody could hear
about what was going on in George
if you lived in Massachusetts but then
you had to have a second vote for
somebody who might be a national figure
and so you had the thought that you'd
have lots of local candidates running
but they wouldn't they wouldn't win and
a few national candidates might be able
to get those those second votes and
related to that was that without the
idea of political parties the the
second-place candidates became the vice
president it would be as if you know
Barack Obama had John McCain as his as
his vice presidential candidate because
that was the person who had the
second-most support now the the people
who sent me the manuscript about the
changes in the electoral college after
1800 are right to say that that our
current system recognizes parties more
we have the the people run as a ticket
right but I'm not sure I don't I don't
know their manuscript as well as I
should but some might say well it caused
that I don't think it caused that we we
talked about not having political
parties but within a few years they
developed very quickly and so are our
system and how they fit fits with
political parties is often a little bit
a little bit difficult to to put
together so they certainly wanted to
encourage people of great stature of
national stature not just local people
in the states they wanted to have a role
for a place for this this mix of state
and national reputation that they see in
the Congress represented in the
presidency as well and you know and
ultimately I think they thought that
that finding big national significant
characters was was one of the the
virtues of the system and has has
something of that today I think we can
forget about today that we have media
and ways of getting famous but there is
a way in which you do have to have some
presence in a number of places today to
become president you can't just be a
regional candidate you can't just be a
television candidate with that office
you have to have to have some of that
and at least that spirit I think is
still was still present in what the
framers wanted
I've tried remember don't they aren't
electors required not to be federal
employees and I don't try and figure if
that was a tradition or actually a
matter of one of the requirements they
are not allowed to be office holders all
right so you can't be I don't know that
they can't be federal employees but you
cannot be office holders so you couldn't
these are funny it is a separate
institution than you hold office I mean
you hold office for a very short period
of time and you cast your vote and you
don't continue on some people I think
tried to portray the actual college as
more of a place that would all come
together meet a kind of legislature not
that but it was meant to be independent
of state government and independent of
federal government so I think again the
idea that the people even even though in
one way the state legislators could
select them they're not doing it
themselves so it's a it is an
independent body that gets elected and I
didn't bring this problem up today some
people worry about this problem of the
faithless elector sometimes these
electors maybe not voting the way we
think they're gonna vote they're
supposed to vote for Bush they vote for
you know they vote for John Kerry and
and it has happened over the years and I
know I think potentially potentially a
problem but there are some problems on
the other side especially if one starts
thinking about what happens if the
presidential candidate dies or something
really horrific happens in terms of
reputation in that in the meantime there
might be a you know some very extreme
cases where there would be a need for
these electors to change their minds but
yes they're not supposed to be federal
they're not supposed to be state office
holders they are supposed to be
independent of the traditional workings
of both go here and then here just got
to get the microphone around here with
regard to one of the arguments against
the college that you take seriously that
it makes some states more important than
others couldn't one make the same a
similar response to that that you made
to the argument that your vote is wasted
right that it simply relocates the
problem to a lower level so then it
would be that major cities become more
important than rural areas and in this
regard it's it doesn't have much force
no I think it's a fair point I mean one
one argument that sometimes made about
the electoral college is that if it
weren't for the electoral college and we
had a national popular vote candidates
would never show up some places they
would really only run via campaigns
nationwide it would only focus on the
big population centers and you know I
think that's more or less true that
there would be a reallocation of
resources of course some of these places
that are that are you know they're
getting attention today would be you
know different than they were so so I do
think that that you know there's some
some truth to that but I guess I wonder
is I think there's an argument for
saying candidates should care about the
majorities in each state shouldn't be
their only concern but they it it's
worthwhile knowing that this country is
not just a bunch of people in Ohio
happened to vote for for federal office
that they actually have some say over
there their local affairs they make laws
they elect officials so the president
having some some basis for his election
in that makes some sense the problem is
I guess if you if you think that only a
few states are swing states you kind of
take for granted those majorities in the
places that you have the advantage or
the other side a state advantage and so
to the extent that you could get people
to take a somewhat broader array of
states more seriously wrestle with their
political cultures you know this it
probably wouldn't be the most extreme
ones the Idaho's and the and the
Massachusetts probably wouldn't get much
attention but there are states that
elect their democratic states is like
Republican governors and vice versa and
having having a little bit of ability
whether it's because you could win a few
electors in some states or few districts
in some states it's something I want to
look at I mean I'm I'm open to this and
we have a group that may do some some
empirical research that just try to
figure out well how many places will be
compared
in these other systems than not but I I
want to hold on to this idea that you
care about States I think there's a
moderating influence in the fact that
the swing states are places that are
toward the middle that the candidates
should should try to persuade but
another side of me says boy 10 or 11 and
we don't have as many swing states as we
used to and that's partly the function
of our polarization and where the states
have moved and I think it's it's a worry
that it'd be better if we had a slightly
broader campaign at the federal level oh
yes sorry if I recall correctly in the
Federalist Papers Hamilton commented
known not only about the people who were
desirable to have as electors but also
that we needed to take great care and
we're talking about a long time ago we
needed to take great care that there
were not foreign entities that were
included in this group of supposedly
virtuous people what foresight they had
and is this affecting anything right now
with the electoral colleges people from
other not only other countries but other
cultures that's an interesting question
I mean certainly every state has there
is a there is a law essentially that you
have to be a US citizen to to vote in
federal elections states that is not in
the Constitution I will vote so you do
not actually have I mean a state could
move towards having resident aliens be
part of the federal electorate they
don't choose to do so but they could
choose to do that you do have some cases
of states or localities having elections
where they say well you're not an
American citizen but you are a longtime
resident here you're a legal resident
here for whatever purpose you part of
our community you can vote so it's not
because of because of law and not the
Constitution
citizens at least legally legally
citizens can non-citizens cannot vote in
federal elections people worry about
this in the case of money I mean trying
to regulate how money comes into the
system some who especially on the on the
side of more campaign finance regulation
say well you know we do have to know
something about who's giving because we
don't want for an interest giving we
want only people who are here in America
giving so and and law that or law again
does prohibit that that's not to say
that some people can't get around that
there aren't there aren't some some some
leakage in some of these areas but if
the federal electoral college or our
electoral laws in general are
essentially for American citizens to
vote and yes of course there are people
who have come here and become American
citizens who are considered just as
American citizen as people who are
naturally born so they're there as equal
as anyone else in terms of this process
but they are our laws even though the
Constitution hasn't absolutely required
this do reflect this idea that you're
that you're saying
this is the final question with the due
regard to how much flexibility the
states have over their voting I really
get depressed when I go home after an
election and I hear reports about voter
fraud and as I understand it the voter
fraud is coming from two sources it's
some of it is defined and it's done on
purpose others it's it's done because by
default in define people are showing up
at the polls and apparently being
allowed to vote when they're not
registered or not even citizens and
apparently the states some states have
tried to counter this by a voter ID by
default a lot of states are simply
letting voter rolls go unchecked what
does the Constitution say about Congress
stepping in and making some of the rules
about voting in the different states as
it applies to presidential elections
make some uniform criteria so that
people in one state are defrauded by
default selections in another state does
the Constitution allow Congress to step
in and let's say have some defined
regulations about voter ID have some
defined regulations about how much you
have to clean up your voter rolls etc
yes it's actually a sort of an
interesting Clause the Constitution that
essentially it says that states may make
laws regarding the times place and
manner of elections
but then federal the federal government
may also make laws which would would
trump them and so at least the the order
of that clause and our history has been
something following that that
traditionally states have the the role
the the primary role in this but there
are some areas where the federal
government has stepped it certainly
there are laws civil rights laws there
are campaign finance laws there's the
law I mentioned about having a uniform
election day you know that so that there
are some things Congress plays in on and
we did after 2000 think fair
about how we hold elections and you know
there was a compromise major bill here
that some Republicans don't like some of
things of it and some Democrats don't
like some things which which did
federalize things a little more certain
certain things about how you there's a
small aspect of how you have to show an
ID if you've never shown one when you
registered in the first time and so
there are some things that the federal
government could do it could weigh in a
very significant way in this I don't
think it's very likely you know I I
wrote another book which is even less
less of a best-seller than after the
people vote called absentee and early
voting promises perils and trends or
subtitle wrong but it's a I think there
are some issues with people showing up
the polls and you know that that's
something we should care about I have
more worries in some ways about some of
these alternative methods especially
absentee voting right that's that's
something that we had some significant
debates in the 19th century about the
secret ballot and there were good
reasons for absentee ballots but there
are also some potential downfalls to it
and why the polling place gives you some
more protections in general election
laws and election administration are
still incredibly state-based so you are
right we have we have shoddy
registration lists partly because
they're hard to keep partly because we
have some laws that say we want to be
sure we keep people on there just in
case you know even though we might think
they might have moved or not sure if
they died we're extra careful and
removing them so so there are a lot of
reasons why we have people on the
election about law roles that that might
not even belong there and it's you know
it's hard to measure outright fraud and
people showing up and impersonating and
I think a lot of people on the other
side of the argument say well there's
not that much evidence of that but it's
certainly true that the the
registrations in this country is
something that is just antiquated
compared to any other country and maybe
with our laws and a lot of money that
we've spent the last ten years we might
be moving to the point where a state
might be able
figure out if you're registered twice in
the state but we certainly couldn't tell
you if you're registered here in one
state in another state or registered in
your maiden name and and also in your
current name so you know all sorts of
all sorts of problems in that and so
this is one issue it's not I guess I
would wouldn't say it's at the level the
Electoral College but one issue that
that both sides of the if you want to
say one side cares about access to
voting then rightly so they care well
people who were registered but their
name didn't get on right or they're
being turned away from the polls
unreasonably or people who think well
the rolls are bad people are showing up
or voting absentee that they shouldn't
and we don't know who's voting we're not
keeping good track they both have a
point right so so in some ways improving
those lists and finding ways of knowing
who really should be able to vote and
allowing them to vote and also keeping
off people who are not eligible or or
duplicate names is something we should
we should work on but it's we barely
sort of scratched the surface of doing
it at the state level and we certainly
have no no federal ability to do that